Speaker 1: Donald Trump gave an interview so
delusional that even the very friendly host,
Darren Beattie, was not able to save him. This
is really something else. And Trump, as we know,
has barely left his house since announcing that he
was running for president for the 2024 Republican
nomination. He is increasingly beaten down and
defeated morally and increasingly a laughingstock.
Doesn't mean he won't be the nominee, doesn't
mean that, but it's getting even more pathetic
than it has been. He was interviewed on Revolver
News by Darren Beattie and he says he is reading
Twitter's only shot at survival is if he goes
back on and abandons his existing platform.
Speaker 2: 12th Century.
Speaker 1: Troth Central. Listen to.
Speaker 2: This. There are those that are saying
that Twitter can never be Twitter unless I go
back and I'm very complimented by that. And I only
said because there are about 20 articles about it,
right. That Twitter can never make it if they
don't have Trump back on. And if you look at
the truth that I put out today and somebody.
Speaker 1: Put out some truths or truths.
Speaker 2: Going to be put out momentarily,
I think you'll see that, you know, that,
number one, they're correct. Number two,
they're good for the country and they are
pretty well crafted. I must say.
Speaker 1: Those truths are nicely crafted.
Speaker 2: I hope you're going to look
at the ones that I just put out. And did
you see the ones I put out today? Yes.
Yes. No, they're very good. And well.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they're just really, really good
troth. I mean, the host sounds like he realizes
how cringe it is to have to tell Trump his truths
are good, but then it gets even worse where Darren
Beattie starts sucking up to Trump saying, Oh,
sir, you're the only guy to keep us out of a war.
And it just gets worse and worse and worse.
Speaker 2: One of the only presidents in a
long time not to bring us into any new wars. And
that's something people really need to appreciate,
especially given all of Biden's failings in the
foreign policy stage. Well, Putin would have
never gone into Ukraine 100%. I used to talk to
him about the zero chance. She would never have
even thought about one, which he is thinking about
seriously. He wouldn't have ever thought about it.
The Afghanistan removal was so bad that it gave
them additional momentum. That would have never
happened. I would have. I was the one that got
our soldiers way down. Yeah, but I would have kept
Bagram, definitely because. Because of China, you
know. Oh, yeah. Away from China's nuclear plants
where they make their nuclear weapons. So
I would have I would have done that. But,
but you know, we would have had the soldiers taken
at least not taken out first in Afghanistan. So,
you know, all those things, those little
mistakes that were made were so bad.
Speaker 1: You know, this idea that Trump's the
only guy in who knows how. Long to keep us out
of new wars or whatever. You know, the truth is.
Jimmy Carter, Gerald Ford, Nixon, they all served
more recently than is often pointed to Eisenhower
and didn't bring the country into new wars. Now,
of course, a lot of this is in the, you know, the
devil is in the details. Are we talking about an
authorized authorization for military force?
Are we talking about bombing or are we talking
about droning? Trump did plenty of droning, and
the phraseology of new wars is so tired, but he
continues repeating it and it's just it's bogus.
Speaker 2: And even on a national scale,
when Putin looked at that boot disaster in
Afghanistan, he said, this is my time to do
it. But, you know, I was the only one in four or
five presidents where Russia didn't take all of
their land back. That made a move at it.
Speaker 1: And again, even that's not really true
because Russia did consolidate its presence in the
dinette scandal, Luhansk and to say take over. I
mean, listen, they didn't announce an annexation
until Biden was president, but they were there.
Every single one of these claims is meaningless.
And even this friendliest of friendly hosts
can't make Trump look like he has any clue what
he is talking about. Join me to a Wednesday,
January 11th, 6 p.m. for the next David Pakman
Show Town Hall. It'll be live streaming and you
can participate on our discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. That'll be 6 p.m. East 3 p.m.
West on Wednesday, January 11th. The David Pakman
show in 2023 continues to be an audience supported
program. You can sign up and support the work
that we do. All of us at join Packman dot com. You
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
get yourself a discount whether you need
it or not. We don't means test the discounts,
take it if you want it. And you also of course
are more than welcome to sign up on any of
the other platforms on which we allow that.